and this just in here at 11 o'clock  Clark County School District confirming  that three juveniles have been arrested  regarding an incident that happened  Friday at Legacy High School  they occurring on Friday again in a  statement to eight news now the district  says while individual student matters  cannot be discussed know that the Clark  County School District actively pursues  all legal actions against anyone  threatening or committing violence on  our campuses or students violating the  CCSD student code of conduct no further  details have been released we'll provide  updates on our website 8newsnow.com